got that one no no no no no
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Dead Space we need
to stop asteroids from blowing up the
ship by fixing ads is that a choice that
you guys have made in the past
do you know what I'm talking about
do you remember Captain anyway
obliteration is imminent which means
that we need to get the heck out of here
more specifically we need to get to the
bridge apparently oh yeah we're going to
join Hammond that's what the deal is if
I remember
there's a security door somewhere here
that's like level one security I don't
know where but I distinctly remember
something like that
occurring right over
right over right over up it was up easy
Zoo down east down is what I meant right
foreign
[Laughter]
oh hi what are you doing here
get out of my way
burn baby burn
that's what you get
okay good see I told you there was
something up here
I knew it
okay not an incredible Bounty but
nothing's good enough
okay seems to be a lot of just plasma
ammo there's not going to be like a
a node
no nodes I was hoping for a node but it
looks like nodes are
fresh out today let me just I'm just
gonna keep moving forwards in case there
was another security door but I don't
think there was pretty sure it was just
straight off to Medical but either way
oh what are you doing here
burn baby
take that
and it seems like it's whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
do you guys respawn
I mean that bodes well for like farming
stuff but it gave me plasma cutter thing
and Pla uh pulse rounds and those are
the only two guns that I have on me if I
just roll
well I don't want to be Med kits oh
those are used oh
what happened to you I'm not a medical
doctor I'm an engineer I solve practical
problems
oh my God
are you okay I don't know what happened
to that guy anyway so that bodes well
because respawning means that I can get
Farming if I need to I mean I don't want
to I kind of want to but I'm gonna go to
the bridge because I'm gonna keep things
moving that little side quest was enough
for me eventually I can explore the
entire ship but maybe I'll just wait
until I get the next security upgrade
and then I can get the level two doors I
know there's level three stuff at the
same time but you know I don't really
want to do that
I wonder what fun special surprises are
waiting for me at the Brew
Isaac I'm looking at the ads cannons
they're a mess I'm gonna need your help
I am not losing the ishimura not now
shimora Hammond for the marker that
artifact they found don't [__] us
CEC no all along about the marker Didn't
They isn't that why you're really here
corporate wouldn't send the ishimura for
some off the books mining but alien
technology yeah that bits and how does
losing my team fit into this Theory hey
knock this [__] off we're into the
debris field we get the ads back
together or it's over and meet me at the
Captain's nest
Daniels
fine
but I'm going through the ship reports
Hammond I'm getting some answers
getting some answers oh uh sorry I
didn't mean to do the God I'm so I
thought the call ended
sooner than that I thought that was uh
well that was awkward uh what is that
main Atrium where would that be
can I jump can I jump is that what is
this the deck where I was talking to
them before is tram control on the other
side no it's not
why can't I grab that well this is
awfully peculiar
this seems to be possibly something that
I can do to get down there but I don't
quite see what it is just yet
to crude deck which way does this want
me to go okay not just yet not yet not
yet not yet
I always got to get all the goodies
because if I don't get all the goodies
then who am I
everyone knows I'm 100 exploratory and
completionist about everything that I do
right guys you all know that
right
you know that about me you can't deny
that about me
that's the truth
hey you know what else ah
you know what else is true about me I
like saving now if I could just not die
call order I see security too who'd even
know uh secured location okay
this doesn't bode well
Hey Big Boy
you're still there okay I thought you
were gone
I probably should have shot you
huh
interesting
um
yeah okay you got me there with the
double
that was something special I um
I'll give you that one
okay but this is good because I'm only
getting ammo for the pulse rifle and the
other thing the only other thing that I
would need like a flamethrower for is
those small dudes but if I have the
pulse rifle then that also works for it
so I don't necessarily need it
keep this I need to get to a bench to
get the pulse rifle upgrade eventually
yeah no this is good
this is all good this is all very good
except for that big thing that's very
bad
oh oh my God
okay interesting
oh boy level two okay
so far
uh-huh so far maybe I should hurry
I just gotta explore
I just gotta
okay I think this is to the bridge
Hammond
I'm just gonna show up in the room and
I'm just gonna go
[Music]
and then he'll be really happy to see me
yeah
that'll be good it's pretty logic it's
hard to come in
Kaiser
sorry
no no keep that rifle close
I'm sad the one that attacked me I mean
it's a trap
oh hi
his face
I'm not seeing things right that's Chen
you can't help him ham it he's
you're right
I should
the hell with it
47 launched I worked with him for years
Johnston too
at least you Spirit becoming a monster
we're gonna fix this Hammond for them
yeah truth come on
I'm an engineer I know how to fix things
it's what I do I'm a fixer relationship
problems fix them every time as soon as
they come up
that's what I do
emotional issues fix them
dogs fix them cats fix them can't spay
though
it's one thing I can't do anyway what
did you tell me to do something I
completely forgot I was I was doing my
own thing let me read this out loud for
you
well the administration systems aren't
doing much we could redirect power from
there I need to rewire the junction box
but we get the ads cannons back
good
okay anyway further to our
Daniel I don't know about any illegal
mining
I swear I'm just here for a repair
Mission
look Hammond I don't know you were
Daniel's well enough to judge but CEC
had to know about the marker the company
Maybe [__] like that's above my pay
grade
look we can get into it later you'll
need a way down to those junction boxes
you can turn the atrium elevators back
on from security you'll have full access
I found a CEC executive key card I'll
upgrade your clearance
and you upgraded yeah just in case and
Isaac
I heard something up there
something big
watch your back
yeah I see something big out there uh
looks like a whole bunch of rocks
um maybe I should be worried about that
first and maybe we shouldn't just be
talking all casually like but anyway uh
cool I'm security too now now I can open
a whole bunch of stuff which would
actually be better to go back and go
look for stuff
but at the same time means I can get
rest of the goodies that are in the
lobby area I'm sure that nothing bad
will happen when I try to do that
just like nothing bad ever happens when
I try to do anything
what is this
[Music]
we are under attack
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute what in the name is that
all right well I was wrong
oh God don't come any closer
hey
oh god wow oh that hurt a lot
oh boy this is uh not ideal
well interesting that doesn't seem to be
effective
ah I got him I got him
oh god oh he's not dead he's not dead
okay hold on we'll take some of these
whoa he's still a come and run who run I
think run
oh that got him oh that's what I thought
I knew it the whole time
why can't I squish you you too tough to
squoosh
why are you too tough to squoosh that
seems a little ridiculous but okay
whatever someone's unsquishable I guess
it wasn't that tough a fight so I didn't
feel that pissed off about it easy
very easy
thank you thank you for the clearance
thank you clearance
video log that's new it's on the record
doctor
the marker must be delivered to the
church whatever the cost God's sakes Ben
listen to yourself
the issue mirrors in crisis you've cut
us off
by maritime law article 5469 I'm Dr
Terence kind here by declare Captain
Benjamin Matthias unfit for Duty
hold him Ben you're not yourself
let me help you Traders get your hands
off me this is my [__]
oh my God he's you Ben
you saw I was trying to help him doctor
you
you just killed the captain
we have to take you in I can't
but the others from the church get a
hold of me
stop
wow that was really professionally
handled glad they wrist sighted old warm
on the bench bendo never mind all right
what do I got uh Power node but what is
the power node a question
special one what is that
greatly increases rate of fire
maybe the best
thing to do would not necessarily be
that but to get some health in my suit
because I seem to be doing terribly
not that I absolutely need
air kinda just need health I'm going for
it I'm doing it all right that's good so
we're upgraded but where were we
supposed to go
elevator
tell me that's an L where's the elevator
you tell me any of this is an elevator
ah that was just to turn it on
okay
well Dooley noted
um
oh Andy that
all right I'll be whoa
that's a good question what uh oh floor
two it says
but what's on floor three
I just gotta find out
I just gotta find out what's on 4043 I
cannot you can't tell me that there's a
floor three and me not go to floor three
I don't want to go to floor three
anymore
I don't I don't think I want to go to
floor three
I don't think four threes for me guys
guys
I was gonna I'll tell you
I don't know if I'm all about fourth
floor three
I like saving dear diary I made a
horrible mistake today
okay
hello
break room
uh-huh
all right wow a recording
huh it must be the marker they took up
so what is this
marker
that's the symbol of the Church of
unitology it didn't take you for a
Believer Isaac
my mother was
but if they found this on some alien
planet
what does that mean that unitology is on
to something
ontology's full of [__] forget it
yeah unitology is full of [__] yeah
United We Ascend and you know unitology
A New Hope or another scam uh if you've
been living on Mars for the past 200
years you might have missed the fastest
growing religious movement in history
unitology boasts a following of millions
counts powerful CEOs and officials in
its ranks claim 78 billion dollars of
stock and multi-global companies and
owns two of Earth's largest financial
institutions wow from its Beginnings is
called the personality unitology has
become a respected established religion
most people know the basics 200 years
ago Michael Altman blew the whistle on
one of the biggest government cover-up
of the marker the government labeled
Altman a kook and his claim struck a
chord with some and his
there's definitely something going on
with the text I don't know what it is
but I know that it's the creeping
influence of the marker on Isaac's mind
which is wonderful anyway unitology
Mausoleum ships or whatever that means
all right at least I got some goodies
also Daniels are you looking through my
eyes the entire time because I feel like
that's some kind of an invasion it's an
electrical hazards on the floor ahead of
you yes
inflating doesn't play well with power
surges watch your steps
yeah
how do I get in there
locked interesting
all right well off I go then
oh goodies
this looks fancy
probably full of enemies
oh there's a baby baby look out baby
ah
interesting and you're dead
well thank you for that
hmm that's different
man I would have thought it would have
been like some kind of War
what is with you
[Applause]
[Music]
let that baby go there it is
oh nice
you still twitching don't
stop twitching
yeesh yeah you know when uh dens when
you said some electrical problems uh I
think you might have underestimated a
little bit
where'd it go
I thought I heard something falling from
event
oh hey
that's one down
that's two down wow
oh what's away
you don't want you
no thank you
and nothing is ever going to even make
it to me
well
and there you go
Stomp
always time for a good stomping
okay
oh
oh no
okay I gotta use my other one because
I'm almost out of ammo on this
oh boy
please don't be a dead end oh my God
Which Way Ring Around the Rosie not that
way
oh oh why did you just did you vomit
because you're so hideously disgusting
oh man I feel like you should be some
kind of dead uh by now
oh boy well I don't have any more stasis
so uh this is really awkward
here to go
again with whatever that is
I know it has a weak spot but it doesn't
seem to want to share oh boy oh I can
make this I can definitely make this
turn around all sick and then stun ya
easy peasy
oh oh no did that Holy oh did that oh
I'm out of ammo oh no did you get hated
no it's too bad for you
that's unfortunate well I got a big
blunt stick I can Bap people around with
I guess there's some pulse rounds that's
what I was looking for let's something
over there
man they're still giving me just a
hundred credits of people whoa
is that a rock or is that a big flesh
thing I never know on this ship it's
always a surprise every time
hmm
interesting I wonder what I have to do
here
take this
oh God don't hit me still you can still
hit me oh God
oh I turn it off
ads cannons
good
ladies
that's one we still need more power a
couple more systems should do it
ah what you mean
whatever what you mean
what's going on here also the the
never mind the flashlight's the same I
thought the flashlight was bigger on
this thing
I might just if one of these turns out
to have a bigger flashlight than the
other I might just pick that
again I suppose a flamethrower is the
biggest flashlight of them all so um
I guess I should be more
available to different weapon choices
but I love the plasma cutter
okay
I did it I'm incredible
so why is that still locked and how do I
get in there I want in there
oh wait a minute
wait a minute oh it's a puzzle oh it's a
puzzle can I just Chuck this at it
nice I mean I had to waste the bullet
whatever it was worth it probably
worth
it hello
three huh interesting
more pulse rounds stasis recharge weapon
upgrade
okay I see that
what is the point of that okay still no
nodes huh I mean I guess I get it from
the big guys but
I always like more nodes
so if I can't go there comms access
all right so comms is a no-go
time to go back
reroute from mining
crap the issue more
of says and the rest I think more
corpses to infect that organic [__] on
the walls that's dead tissue too the
crews thought it was a
habitat changer Isaac I'm gonna run some
Diagnostics
I think that's best spreading
then you do that I'll save that's what
I'll do go team we have a plan so you
know if this whole thing was taking
place long enough to study on this ship
I know I know what the whole deal is I I
think I do but
the church people on the ship wanted to
keep the marker aboard and then other
people were like Hey we're all dying and
we'd really not like to do that and the
captain was all like no I think we're
all gonna die and that's really cool
because um that's the whole point of
unitology we all die and then get
schmooshed together into one great
glorious Gloom
welcome to mining Administration
whoa
yep didn't save him there was nothing I
could do oh
I couldn't say wait a minute I see
something over there get out of the way
whoa never mind I got it
hell yeah anything else out there
[__]
what do we got storage room yes please
oh oh sorry uh that's my bad
yeah that would have been my bad
okay
nice nice oh thank you
that's a lovely reprieve I don't know
why you're able to get air in here it
feels like it wouldn't be useful
this chip has enough oxygen just to open
and close these things willy-nilly but I
guess no one else is breathing it so it
doesn't really matter
I thought I heard something Records
Office huh
well time for a pit stop I suppose
thank you
uh I'm so sorry I'm
sorry
uh sorry
no personalies
what am I a contact Energy oh
ah the contact beam
when you want something really
unbelievably incredibly dead
yeah you do use the contact beam that
that is true I'm not gonna deny that
that's very true not very familiar with
the weapon but I have a funny feeling if
I did use it I'd have a good old time
heavy energy projector that launches a
continuous lethal beam asteroid cutter
charges and releases a single shot so
that's what you really want to use is
the big old blowy upy button
um at least that's what I'm guessing so
I'll keep that on me
because if I'm not mistaken I bet the
ammo for that is worth a pretty penny
hello
goodbye
take this boot
take this that's not what I want oh God
there we go
thank you for that
you guys are extra goopy
some kind of tall for version
hmm
interesting well not Tough Enough For Me
I'm just too big and strong
am I supposed to go here no but I will
go in here ah that looks important I
should probably not break it
I don't know why my first instinct would
be to break it but
funny urge
oh well no
good
now what did that do
I'm an engineer I'm assuming I know what
I'm doing so I can just start smacking
everything willy-nilly maintenance admin
fascinating
uh-huh
[Music]
thank you thank you clearance
node a I like node
text log a trying to work out how fast
they spread the flight deck was the
first to go probably thanks to that
shuttle crash most of the medical is
overrun and losing ground by the hour
engineering can't be that far behind no
word from cargo or communication so not
expecting anything but bad news when we
do our best soap seems to be the mining
deck Dallas says the infrastructure down
there is still running but if they took
out security that fast how long could we
hold down well it turns out mining
slicing and dicing is exactly the kind
of stuff that you need
bullets ain't do nothing which uh begs
the question of why I even used the
pulse rifle in the first place
all right my dudes
I heard something
well I gotta check all the side paths
okay we got a bench
oh
Locker
I get that you know it has to be dark
but you'd think that this would provide
just a little more illumination
a little more
you know how many I got four okay damn
oh and another one for the pulse rifle
oh wow what did that do greatly
increases ammunition and whatever
capacity is basically all this thing has
it's got nothing but capacity that's so
much capacity who needs that much
capacity who needs that much capacity
when you get one more damage yes please
thank you very much
all right why are you movable
I feel like that was movable for a
reason
you're like something there was obvious
but I didn't see what it was
okey-dokey then
all right
oh
baby where where I don't see baby
where is it
anybody seen what I'm not seeing well
that's that's not good oh there you are
oh well
hi
three what how tough are you
stop
rude what
what
oh hey
there we go that's more like it
thank you
all right cool we're moseying
as some light what is this light no way
wow
he's beautiful oh
okay mining I probably shouldn't do this
but here I am doing it
should've got nothing power diverted
from mining Administration Network
that's two one more system and we'll
have power for the ADF
hmm what was it
where oh oh no no no oh I didn't I
didn't oh I didn't oh I didn't clear the
oh wait a minute no no no you don't want
to do that you don't want to do that
okay all right yeah well that's one down
oh boy you got glow yeah no no no we
don't need any of that what oh
whoa whoa
oh God
there we go I was stuck on vertical
there and I didn't want to risk changing
it to horizontally
in case there was a
urgent problem which apparently there
was
thank you
okay well let's never do that again
always remember to Stomp all the bodies
no personalies
oh hi
I don't like that you're still glowing
that's uncomfy
hooky I already been the Records Office
okay
good good good great great good sure
would be a bad time for something to pop
out and try to stab me
it's all good it's all good
hello
all right
I like saving okay by the way did you
know that you can get your very own Dead
Space merch at
cloakbrand.com where you can get your
very special customized health bar on
your back is retro reflective
is very nice only available at
cloakbrand.com Link in the description
so now I go to floor two
four one
wait am I on floor oh right I did go to
floor that's right
I need to go to floor one now into verb
power that's right why didn't I just do
that first uh because the thing
suggested me or else I would have I
never do it in order what
was my brain going scrambled there for a
hot second
no you don't
anyone else anyone else wants them
you
I thought as much
Oh weird
my brain just got scrambled for us hot
second there
okay I just need the store all right I
got a lot to sell and a lot to do
Yee a super symmetry tether who the hell
does that mean oh look at it all
[Music]
right so sell this yeah help
sell that sell that sell that and oh do
I want the contact beam
I don't really sell that contact beam
not yet anyway there will come a time
when I gotta face some really really big
baddies and I'm gonna want that heavy
Firepower I'm pretty sure I'm gonna want
this that's why I'm not gonna sell this
ammo because I know I'm gonna need it
but for right now I just need to gather
oh but if I needed then I should
probably carry it there's gonna come a
time when I'm gonna want a very big boom
no
it's gonna come a time when I want a
very big boom and I'm not gonna be able
to do it because I've sold it stupidly
God why did I oh but that hurt a lot
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna want the big
Kaboom oh
I hate I'm so mad
why was it the button to sell it oh I
just wanted it out of my storage why
would they make that the top button the
game is literally unplayable
other upgrades how do I make this hit
harder secondary fire damage primary
fire damage why are they split increase
the size of a bigger projectile I kind
of like that I have six nodes when did I
get six I have no idea oh you Salvage a
node out of them right that's right I
forgot about that you know what there's
gonna come a time when I want a very big
Kaboom and I want to be able to know
that I have the biggest Kaboom possible
I'm gonna operate the contact thing I'm
not gonna use it immediately that's the
thing that's that's the thing everyone
needs to understand I'm probably not
going to use it even remotely
immediately no no way see already 600
dims that's a lot of damage but I'm not
going to use it now and I've lost 15
bullets to use with that which hurts but
I'll get over it
why
why did you open
yeah oh you're still here oh yeah
oh that's not what I meant
oh yeah
well all right then
I think I'm supposed to go here
then
science provides Bounty like Bounty
Hunter Bounty or what kind of bounty are
we referring to
[Music]
okie dokie then
um that's fine Elizabeth Jacob
I came to the bridge looking for you but
it is completely [__] I'm not sticking
around in case whatever did it comes
back and neither should you
it looks like the admin staff went to
the mining deck to meet up with the
other survivors I'll head there too
if you aren't with them
I'll find a way to contact you
all right good luck
one engineer to another good luck to you
I'm pulling for you I really am all
right it's restocking me back up whoa oh
no wait wait I got how do I slice you
good
got that one no no no no no no
thank you
thank you don't do it don't do it
get those limbs get those limbs why are
those limbs not gone oh my God no
I'm whapping you and I'm blapping you
that went terribly
and I got 100 credits for my trouble
I hate you
yeah all right that feels better
um
I'm supposed to go there but what about
exterior access
that sounds super duper fun
I'm not ready for that yet
all right let's do this
80s
ah interesting
oh we got it the 80s cannons are back
online we wait Auto targeting offline
calibration data not found [__] no Auto
targeting the Cannons are useless well
that's not good manual targeting you
want to go out there with all that [__]
raining down and Target the ads cannons
manually yeah if I get the Cannons
enough targeting yeah it'll recalibrate
the system you got a better idea Christ
a little bit exterior access I hope you
know what you're doing I mean I'm an
engineer
firearms training is all part of the the
equation
oh hey what's up prep
oh
all right semiconductor all right
intermediate engineering rig status
I don't know what that means but I like
it
love it love it like it love it what is
thumping out there oh the asteroids
right I forgot about that right right
right
asteroids right right asteroids
asteroids
I should heal
or should I
yeah I should go I yield
hello
my tools my target
Droid the Cannons take it out and I
recalibrate the system we're out of
options do it I was gonna
I was already gonna so you don't need to
worry about it
security request retrieved
oh God
the Second Officer Sheikh I need
security here right now
for Christ's sake step away from the
control we need our first officer
Captain Messiah
who's left
that's an order who's left sheets oh a
crew full of uni fanatics
Eckhart screwed us good didn't he if a
FEC director could go that bad
maybe the whole company's rotten to the
core
just like ages seven you've been saying
there's a precious Planet cracker big
white
we just need to hold on oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God
what is this what is this nonsense what
is happening oh my God this is terrible
changing targeting system yeah okay oh
my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
okay
okay compromise yeah okay all right well
destroy asteroids too baby
oh
interesting
[Music]
ah
oh ah who did that
let's shoot myself
fascinating
maybe is there a baby around
I'm basically a baby I don't see a baby
I don't see any baby
[Music]
I can't oh there you are God
I need air I need air I need air I need
air I was very confused as to what's
happening don't ask why I'm just very
apparently bad at this game all of a
sudden
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
am I gonna die oh my God
oh my God oh my God
thinking targeting system
take out that one oh e
right
oh boy
yay man I could have been done a lot
sooner
good good good
that's one
I die no I know look I just decided to
give myself a bit of a head start
oh my God
good good good good good I'm definitely
gonna make it we're definitely gonna
make it
we're doing great what was that
that was definitely important to stop
and get
targeting system
data migration complete okay what is
that recalibrated
Auto targeting systems enabled
they're back the ADF cannons are online
shipwide thank God engaging autopilot
get yourself inside Isaac I think I
figured out our next move I did
okay well it's not letting me over there
uh we got we actually got invisible
walls here
Ah that's no fun
come on let me explore
okay I got White's rig I don't even know
what that means
I don't know if that's what I was
looking for or gonna help me or is this
special suit that only I can wear if I'm
a really big big boy
I don't know what it is but what I do
know is that I have done the impossible
and hey look at that ship I know I bet
there's another special goodie out here
that I could get if I was really really
meticulous about it but I'm all right
I'll survive without it I think anyway
it just caught me off guard with uh
all right
I am low on health
man I've been taking some hits that one
baby was just able to wail on me for a
very long time what am I seeing
uh something tells me my mind might not
be mine
I just intercepted a transmission for
medical no one's down there see what you
make of this
senior medical officer Nicole Brennan
medical is a sanctuary
all survivors please join us
I'm going back to Medical
makes sense I'll head to the crew deck
and look for survivors from the bridge
I'll be in touch
wonder if you know something we don't
even using me videos
of the baby talk
yep
looks like uh
that's the end of the chapter which
means that's the end of this episode
is Nicole really in medical does Hammond
know something that he's not telling us
find out in the next episode of
breathing